[Applause]
[Music]
way
[Applause]
as McKinnon's dragging him off the bench
the Puck's now gone up the ice so as he
crawls off someone's jumping on on the
other side they're screaming that it's
too many men there's finging you just
saw him going by he we have both Josephs
have been clipped can you what are the
chances of that Joseph on Joseph and
it's both Josephs and the only penalty
is going to be should only be against
po Pittsburgh number 73 this is
impossible at what I'm seeing right now
for sticking it's only happens in
Hollywood this is impossible their
parrots can't believe believe it no Mom
has to
laugh so it's Poo's own stick there own
stick and they both get high sticking
tamy panon actually took his glove off
and threw it across right over me to
Brad Maran we'll see if we can get a
look at it uh here right behind the
linesman and uh it was I mean to laugh
cuz it is heated very intense
but
they're trying to find the where is the
P they're trying to find the Pucket he
got up in
hisia Danny used to say where is the
puck
hello the way he stopped it and he fell
over it's it's falling down in his
pantser in his pad and the problem is
you can leave it in there and all of a
sudden it falls out during play then you
got a real problem careful now there it
is the old hidden p
and the faithful here in Montreal react
that's pretty good and here's the shot
by Zub goes right up the pat leg
celebration
excitement but she doesn't need to leave
it there she really gets after the
goenda have
it Bo she's having a
blast maybe a little bit too much fun a
glove save a great save on the face off
win by flick the glove see him flick the
glove
nice some things that we haven't seen
before you see Ben Harper he's ducking
he's trying to get out of the way and
Harper says hey good job lead now here's
Skinner going to get rocked right over
on the bench right there and he's just
going to be left there nobody even
helping him he fights to get back out on
the ice himself regains control of the
Pucket comes right back to him escapes
good stick though by Kale ma to knock
that puck out of play or there may have
been a break down the left wing for Bor
strand that guy really enjoyed making
that catch for this one that it's a lot
to take in especially this look at this
during warm-up still getting used to the
labels on the water bottles trying to
cool himself off he realizes wait a
second that's not clear that's that's
pink I just sprayed myself with bioeel
makes the switch and is able to hose
himself down properly so slid far enough
that he was able able to get it out that
was a Oh scores from L
rings from Hanahan and then a missplay
by Smith and a long shot that Smith
unable to gather likely put out there by
Daryl Sury in anticipation giveway here
Stars newon Hopkins with this team
earlier he went to play a puck he was in
the no play zone the better Puck
handlers in the game but this is an easy
one to just play to the side and he
decides to turn to his right and play it
on his forehand but the heel of his
stick there raises and the puck just
goes right underneath good for aari for
keeping his stolen by G just out of his
reach long pass marks him out the pl G
away they score Thompson with the steal
from marstrom puts it in and the Savers
win in overtime and the puck gloved out
oetkin pulled
down pedal sure if we might
have both no I don't think there's a
penalty nothing I even know vkin agreed
there no penalty okay they're both
shaking their head everyone's shaking
their head here's a there's no penalty
on the play there's no
penalty it was just a little push it
wasn't much yeah I know see v he's he's
basically saying no no no no penalty and
a Harland the safe bottle of
WI
[Music]
here with the Panthers and what can you
say about David poock only Conor McDavid
had more than his 61 goals he joins Phil
espito for Minnesota our Verizon
reliable performance well Ryan Reeves
he's been
hot contract here down to the wire
finding some offense proving that he can
do more than just toss the
gloves so he's going to need a little
bit more help than that Rooney not
versed in the equipment but right off
the top of the mask and look where the
puck ended up here
guys that's like Jonesy that's like when
you play roulette did by Verizon Matt
duchaine making friends wait wait hey
give it to the
kid come on no I can't see that
sign there it is Airline Center I don't
know I still don't know how Jamie didn't
tuck it home the puck rolled a little
bit flipped caught the top of his stick
blade there was just nothing but net I
mean a chance to win it for the Rangers
stro moves in on Grace stro missed
wide